si tu parles de sexe dans le livre un
sujet tabouin non pas encore j'espère
sur le dans le tome 2 un sujet tabou
mais pas pour toi qui décide qu'ils
décident de te confier de dévoiler de
nombreux détails tu assumes ton
libertinage dans le livre tu racontes
quelques détails et ce côté de ta
personne ne plaît pas tout le monde dans
ton entourage tu dis j'ai toujours fait
ce que j'ai voulu de mon sexe et de mes
solitude j'aime autant les énamourir
romantiques que les travestis du bois de
Boulogne exactement
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis pas un pervers ma vie
sexuelle s'arrête au consentement de
l'autre bien sûr j'ai jamais violé
personne c'est pas mon truc je regarde
pas les films porno un stream tease ça
me laisse complètement froid mais c'est
vrai que je suis un amoureux de la
liberté et dans le milieu libertin c'est
pas que du cul c'est une façon d'être et
dans le milieu dans ce milieu là qui est
libre et bien il y a pas de riche il y a
pas de pauvres il y a pas de moche il y
a pas de beau il y a du respect et s'il
y a pas le respect ça n'existe pas donc
c'est un monde qui me plaît voilà alors
après j'ai aucun souci avec ça Patrick
c'est vrai que c'est fou ce que tu dis
parce que alors là il y a un souci avec
la morale seulement la morale c'est
l'ennemi du moral mais tu as déjà été tu
faisais quoi avec les travestis du mois
de septembre
la première chose que je leur demandais
c'est quel est le dernier animateur qui
est passé vous voir
[Rires]
quand les prochains jours
il y avait d'autres mais ah ouais non
mais c'est fou de dire ça dans un livre
parce que si je suis un infidèle
chronique et un libertin assumé je n'ai
aucune barrière si ce n'est celle du
consentement comme ça je m'interdis tout
comportement qui pourrait dévaluer mes
partenaires multiples mais j'ai toujours
été un collectionneur invétéré et si
j'en ai la possibilité je ne laisserai
passer aucune occasion si furtif
soit-elle sans aucun a priori d'âge ou
de beauté
[Rires]
absolument dans les dans les relations
que j'ai eu à ce que mon regard d'après
soit le même que celui d'avance qui est
pas le cas de tout le monde mais j'ai de
l'estime pour toutes celles que
j'appelle des passants que j'aime
énormément
moi il y a un truc qui me gêne dans
l'amour traditionnel c'est la
possessivité voilà j'estime que
j'appartiens à personne et que personne
ne m'appartient et c'est en ça c'est
très féministe parce que je te dis
encore une fois ce que j'aime dans mes
relations c'est que l'autre soit heureux
même en dehors de moi
elle le savait ton ta femme comment elle
le savait ta femme passe
évidemment qu'elle savait des choses et
puis elle est elle en a d'autant plus de
de mairie c'était un deal il y a eu un
deal entre nous
il y a surtout un deal de respect mutuel
dans le fond parce que j'ai jamais
triché sur ce que j'étais il y a
tellement de mecs qui promettent à leur
femme d'être des modèles et qui ne s'y
tiennent tu dis ça pour castagner
en plus je n'ai jamais demandé une
je suis pas du genre à dire moi je fais
ce que je veux à la maison tu vois c'est
voilà c'est ce qui s'appelle un couple
moderne avec un respect mutuel avec
beaucoup d'admiration parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration je crois que
c'est marié quatre fois comme moi je me
suis marié quatre fois et je me suis
planté un peu quatre fois mais c'est
parce que je suis pas fait pour ça quoi
tu dis je suis bien trop libertaire
ouais la liberté pour moi est quelque
chose essentiel et c'est vrai que dans
ce livre j'en dévoile un petit peu plus
que d'habitude je dévoile pas tout non
plus mais c'est pareil c'est pour
essayer d'aider des gens qui tu sais les
il y a des crimes passionnelles tous les
jours quand je vois les gens se
déchiraient sur tu en as tous les jours
des buzz comme ça
sur la gueule se tape dessus à la
moindre séparation on l'écrit tu dis
j'ai pas envie de vivre ça tu dis tu dis
tu es libertin mais pas échangiste non
c'est pas la même chose
en fait
[Rires]
les libertins
personnages Molière champ de la fontaine
et en plus si tu remarques bien dans
leur œuvre c'est des gens qui avaient
une acidité par rapport à la société il
se trouve que j'ai aussi ce truc là ça
va mais tu vas dans tu vas dans des
clubs et tout
c'est un ami c'est un ami m'appelle
jamais pour sortir avec lui c'est un
truc de fou Patrick c'est pas c'est pas
aussi réducteur que ce caca c'est pas
aussi réducteur que que ce que tu dis
j'ai beaucoup d'amis avec on peut passer
des soirées à discuter mais on discute
sans faire à poils
forcément mais quelle est la différence
entre le libertinage et l'échangisme
l'échangisme c'est du troc c'est ça
c'est-à-dire je te donne une fille que
je te donne
le libertinage c'est une manière
d'aborder la vie et la sexualité d'une
manière avec élégance c'est la
définition du dictionnaire avec
avec toutes les libertés
des couples qui s'échangent c'est du
trocs je les ai jamais amené dans des
endroits comme ça je suis toujours allé
en célibataire parce que tous mélangent
parce que en plus c'est le c'est le
tarmac pour les c'est le serment pour
les chevaliers du yel parce que c'est il
y a tout le tout le côté LGBT qui
représenté chacun est libre de faire ce
qu'il veut voilà je dis attends je
prends pas pour ça je dis pas fait ça
mais le livre le livre de Patrick est
formidable parce que je me sens pas ça
en fait comme moi je suis comme ça je
j'en ai pas honte parce que je ne fais
rien pourquoi non il respectueux
exactement moi tout le reste c'est moi
je sais mais il y a pas de harcèlement
chez les libertins il y a pas de viol il
y a pas de manque de respect parce que
le premier manque de respect c'est
dehors tu fais plus partie de la troupe
donc c'est un monde qui me va plutôt
bien voilà et quand tu as mais je pense
pas que ça
parce que tu me connais voilà c'est ça
ça m'a intéressé aussi c'est normal
les mecs ou pas
[Applaudissements]
raconter des parts de ton intimité s'il
te plaît non mais bye parce que je suis
sûr que tous les spectateurs c'est vrai
que c'est Patrick tu imagines moi
j'habite à côté
parce qu'il y a
il y a vraiment énormément de choses en
livre comme je vous l'ai dit alors il y
a un truc aussi du livre c'est ça c'est
que il faut rester vivant
tout ça même ces histoires de sexe et
cetera donc je suis pas je suis pas un
obsédé non plus non ça fait partie de la
vie c'est vivre c'est comme manger c'est
comme tout ça ça fait partie de la vie
voilà moi je préfère tu sais je cite je
cite plus tard au début de du livre qui
disait il faut pas il faut pas naître
pour exister il faut naître pour vivre
car moi je préfère vivre voilà alors